okay for those on this livestream this
is another episode in our internal
design reviews for the next version of
Wolfram language this particular one is
about displaying automatic proofs and
why don't we start by looking at an
example here so do I have to run this
thing this is that is that necessary to
run that or is that unnecessary at this
point if you're using for the reveal
that's unnecessary
okay okay so here so let's just try to
understand what's happening with this
okay so did did we get any input from
graphic design on these things or has
that not happened yet was discussed this
morning with them and we have been
focusing amazingly on the natural
deduction diagrams the I wonder if we
can see whether Jeremy again see if he's
available yep thanks um so basically
they only had comments on colors for the
proof networks otherwise they said they
look okay
all right well let's try okay so this
so now you've now defined this new proof
object correct yes yeah so the idea is
that they will have as first argument
the type of logic we are using so that
it's reusable in the future with other
proofs coming from Lee Exeter
okay so what so how do I use this so
this right now wouldn't have any more
information but we have methods to
extract information like live network so
Jonathan knows but by the way there's
okay this is hardly beautiful I mean it
may be beautiful in functionality but
it's totally beautiful in graphic design
um now what what's your really funky
this human readable thing which by the
way I think is a really weird name but
okay so what is this and what how is it
formatted so this is a this is producing
a notebook documents from dramatically
and it's just taking every proof step so
every note that's in the proof network
displayed above and it's providing just
for each expression that appears in each
proof step it's providing a natural
language description of what the
significance of that expression is so
for the substitution learner it's saying
we prove this lemma by taking this
object hypothesis one we applied this
substitution which is justified by axiom
one yeah okay but but so the fact that
it's a substitution lemma camel cased is
a little weird here right yeah yeah we
have that spaced and yeah okay so the
next thing is we need somebody who knows
about notebook design which means
probably Andre assembly in that group
okay can we see if we could find Andre
of Andres available just for a couple of
minutes here um okay hey Jeremy the way
we are looking at these some proof
diagrams and so on have you so first of
all this this thing here with its Brown
group and blue is coming from some kind
of layered graph plot thing right is
that true Jonathan so there's a new
version of played' graph plot isn't
there
but that version of the function we're
using I think we're using layered graph
plot you in a your audio is breaking up
um yes so he was saying that we are
using the new version from for the roof
networking so I I don't
Oh for the proof network but what about
for this thing here I think that's still
the old one okay so that needs to be
fixed because colors are really yucky um
logic equational logic are we calling it
equation what are some other examples of
logics well in the future we'll have
things like first-order logic or
negative logic or intuitionistic logic
just sort of thing okay do we want to um
okay but do we do we want the name of
the logic to be equational logic or do
we want the name of the logic to be
equational I don't know okay I'm back
okay hey Andre um we are looking at this
this is automated theorem proving stuff
and we as an automatic notebook
generator and the styles of this
notebook leaves something to be desired
yeah it looks to me like a king on
format one of those cells like just even
the text cell that one's fine it wasn't
wrong to begin with but show me the
textile there there's no so that would
be why how is this being generated
Jonathan is there a template that you're
using some is just alright well
obviously he could be connecting with us
and we can help him out here so I think
I'll just make sure we follow up with
him on this is that right
well yeah Jonathan are you there yep
yeah can you explain is there a notebook
template that this comes from no no it's
right now it's just a it's just a bunch
of cells that are being generate
it's programmatically but yeah what's
the right way to get this designed and
cuz just putting in the style we make a
particular style right yeah I mean you
if you want it to look better than it is
now you could just use the default style
sheet styles but it does seem like maybe
it needs something more than that if
there's well the only problem is that if
it isn't default style sheet it's just
think it through for one second okay
this this thing can we make it more
complicated one of these Jonathan yeah
there should be plenty of examples in
the documentation if you scroll down bit
more dubby that mean that that's a
reason the complication one there this
one here yeah the properties in the the
axioms are in two parts
you
I was fast
cost
okay so it goes for a while
nice and fast at least but but Stephen
the theory is that these would always be
put in this kind of framing device you
have on the page is that right well
that's a notebook that's just a notebook
object isn't it
that's just displaying a notebook object
correct yep they're embedded notebook
objects then many people will click that
just has anybody tried this in the cloud
does it work in the cloud with hands
right yet um so those the code that is
there do you expect that to just be
input or do you expect it to be some
other form of code format Jonathan that
can be in a sense it doesn't really
matter whether it's input or whether
it's not no but it might as well be
input because that way people write copy
paste it yeah yeah I mean I guess it
makes more sense if it is so I mean just
naively this this would become a a text
cell I guess I can just do well actually
probably code text right it's not much
different than a computational NSA
really is it no it isn't different so
that that would be a good code text cell
but now how do I get that to code text
style well were we giving you a shortcut
for that yes but that was based on docu
tools being up them you get doggy tools
up even though doc utils wasn't working
here um and we're having trouble
reproducing that problem so do I have to
understand why it's a problem for you
and not anyone else okay Roger - I mean
somebody suggested that that was because
it had set some notebook - no okay but
now this cell I don't know Stan why this
is this is a small I don't even
understand what form format this will
just put comma code text and
you know return that yeah there you go
okay okay so then this would be
beautiful it's right I mean these could
all have been created that way yes I
mean it might be faster for Jonathan to
edit his his so one thing that's gonna
happen if they're all input is gonna be
a lot of blue on this page
she's probably okay well and that's part
of why I was asking like does that
matter to you guys or not no I think
this is perfectly nice I think it's
certainly nicer than what it had before
there now what is that cell that's a
subsection cell possibly it shouldn't be
a subsection cell but it should be a sub
subsection like that now okay so what
you have here is something women proof
so proof is a sub case of this right so
this is critical pair lemma one and then
it has a proof right yep so naively if
this was if that was a six and that was
proof and maybe proof got italicized
maybe maybe it doesn't get italicized I
don't think the italics are helping
there um in our in our publishing based
style sheets of which we still have a
few we do have style definitions for
proofs and lemmas and all those kinds of
things but they're in the context of you
know journal publication and I'm not
sure that's what we want to apply here
no and also where you have an input and
don't have an output it it kind of
affects the margins a bit you know
outputs have more margins below them
than inputs do so that there's a bit of
fussiness here if you're not going to
evaluate any of this stuff it doesn't
make any sense to evaluate it I think
unless unless these are output cells but
I don't think what makes more sense
there well if instead of input they
could be code right there we have a few
other styles to consider let's let's go
here that's that's a seven
yeah you see look that's not gonna work
because this this code text style is set
up to be a one-shot caption not a
continuation of text right I mean this
doesn't look terrible it looked better
it looks better than did before well
alright so then maybe don't use the code
text and just make that command seven
there you go okay and so all you're
really saying is for what they're
generating throw text and input in there
for now well and subsection and this
becomes a a what is that that cell that
is a subsection cell right so these are
the only elements Jonathan yeah yeah you
at most you're gonna have a subsection
like critical element and then a proof
there's no and there's no other sort of
hierarchy to it okay and and we think
okay are you able to just in real time
modify this code and just try seeing
what one of these notebook objects looks
like and with this by the way sub
pattern obviously if we're gonna use
something we should put add it to a
spell checker hey sushma could you do
that yes um since we don't want every
single proof that comes out to have
spelling mistakes in it or to have a
parent spelling mistakes in it um some
things no no it's okay we'll modify the
spell checker so it won't pick up sub
pattern as a spelling error all right no
sorry I meant modified the the add the
output third right so question guys if
if we were to put a background color on
some of these things which would not
hurt anything do you think that would
make this look so remember this is what
it's going to look like the other
possibility is that we could close up
proof there by default
and this like that a human-readable
thing it might also want to have the
opener the group opener right but we're
getting group openers by default an 11-3
yes for this case um Jonathan I know
you're paying attention something
different but what do you think about
the idea of closing the proofs up by
default that sounds good yeah no because
it that will that will fit with our sort
of format for displaying the proof steps
more sort of better than it does at the
moment because by default if you request
the list of proof steps it will only
show these of high-level members and
things and you can request to drill down
and see the proof see I guess for
consistency or make sense have that okay
um and what does it say at the end of
the whole thing does it say QED no it
just says we obtain the conclusion true
magnificent okay um you could say there
you go well alright so can you let me go
every later
Jonathan you got to be able to modify
this in real time or not I'm I'm gonna
see what I can do but okay okay um okay
so by the way I hope you have my nice
boolean algebra thing in here as an
example
yup it's like I think
seen that one multiple times so
therefore I know what it looks like
yeah I'm sure work out the the thing you
just proved that was a different boolean
algebra thing but that's also that's
also some axiom system for NAND but it's
not the one that you want I think all of
all of the ones that use they're like
the single NAND axiom all of those
proofs are too long I felt to be
reasonably generated by I can add them
no you should absolutely have them in
the application section here sure yeah
um okay
so
let's go through the question so for
Jeremy there's the question of what
these things look like right so we've
got this is ridiculously long actually
we've got two things we've got the data
set and we've got what is that that's
the proof network right so this their
percent nine proof network
well that doesn't look so bad actually
yeah we looked at this this morning for
a bit we're gonna update the colors and
there was some default labeling which
actually looked okay don't you think
that the dash is a really coarse here I
think they would look better as finer
dashes do they right dashed versus solid
they mean something in this system yes
Linda okay yeah different color I mean
what does the dotted what do the dashed
lines mean so the the - lots of you get
that the solid lines show where a
construct is being used as an input to
some rule and the - lot I'm sure it
where contractor being used is the
justification for a rule okay
what do you mean input well okay so did
you come up with a different color
palette that actually means something
because I don't know what Northeast
colors mean
you know what we could consider having a
proof network captioned property here
captioned or labeled legend ed
is okay in which there is an actual
caption that explains what these things
are
does that make sense it's a legend of
explaining the types color types yes
okay because there's a labeled version
of this which has no there is labels
yeah well there's a threshold is if
there are less than ten notes then they
get labels we should have a way how do
you get it labeled if it has more than
ten nodes there isn't a way at the
moment but we can add some kind of
overrides why don't we say proof network
labeled is the labeled version because
somebody might want to make a whole wall
chart out of this that's fair enough
but our reason for excluding it was that
the labels right
the default is correct but you're right
like what you're doing by default no
problem with that
right now there are Buddhist yeah I see
that I see that but I think proof
network and proof network labeled so
these are all properties of the proof
object right so
so is proof network a graph is that
thing there a graph yes Graham no that's
a graphic oh sorry yeah it's a graph
that's being put into layered growth
plot new but does layered graph plot
actually produce a graph or not it may
produce a graphics I I don't know
can we find that out can can somebody
see if it can reach Charles blue see if
you can join us okay
I'm calling them now okay well the fact
that the directive interface is showing
frame labels exceeded our product points
in the direction probably a graphic it's
a graph lies yeah so the question is we
also need something where this is an
actual graph right I'm making sense
because somebody won't matter manipulate
it as a graph right so that's another
should proof network by default display
a graphic or I don't know returning that
what I don't know it will be much better
if the same if those two things were
equivalent if you understand what I mean
in other words if there was a way of
specifying in the graph that the layout
should be a grant a layered graph plot
right so that the whole thing can then
be an actual graph that can be
manipulated um okay let me let me see
some other cases so first of all what
are the horrifying okay so again I'm
sorry let's talk about this picture
let's look at a simpler one first okay
so this is a simpler one with labels the
labels are really kind of ugly and the
fact that those dots get bigger is
really pretty horrifying
is that do we know how to fix that do
you know what that is is that how are
those got specified so you understand my
problem that if I if I resize this thing
those dots are getting super big um also
this font where is this font coming from
is that a default text font or what
that's a default for vertex labels
versus a bling automatic so I whatever
they define the defaults and which help
etiquette Arial okay um why does this
look so incredibly ugly Jeremy it's too
big for the data it doesn't need to be
that big I don't know how you scaled at
the dots but it's actually not changing
size which is the problem right it's not
getting smaller as you write okay so
that's so that may be the issue that we
may need to have some defaults and that
may be an issue for layered graph plot
because layered graph plot was supposed
to be something I mean graphs in general
are supposed to lay out at a size that
depends on how much data is in them
mm-hmm okay so I think this is an issue
there and that would be fixed if this
didn't so let's take a look at a
slightly larger one as this er wears a
slightly larger one um
I think in applications there are some
group theory proofs that are a little
bit longer what happened to your end
that we'll all know an axiom equation I
assume systems do you have that
someplace no because so if we had this
equation or theory function which would
return axioms systems but we decided in
in the ILD meeting we discussed whether
it'd be better to have an association
and then I think on Saturday you
suggested having having the axiom
systems as resource objects yeah my
suggestion was just put a single for now
just have a single data repository entry
that has the axiom the no and axiom
systems in it yeah right so that's a
there would be one every one resource
object for all equational axiom systems
that we have that's what I think we
should do for now I mean eventually you
know with luck there'll be so many of
these things that we'll want to break
them apart into their own repository
mm-hmm my concern that is how do we can
we actually represent them how do we
represent the resource object in such a
way that we can parameterize the axiom
systems you get out so you know you have
a user request an axiom system for
abelian group theory or something and we
don't want the user to have to use the
defaults multiplication operator or
something which mean like the default
might be gee but maybe the user wants to
use mult how do we allow that we can't
just have like an association I think
okay so let's understand that oh so
jeremy by the way that's the I mean the
fact it would be really good if Charles
was found um I'm here oh okay all right
well question for you and then let's go
back to this resource data thing okay so
we're using layered graph plot here or
some kind of layered graph layout is
there a way of getting graph to lay
itself out as a layered graph graph
layout option so wait a minute so so
women so then you will get the same
looking layout as this is an 11-3
prototype builds here so so what do you
do hey Jonathan do you have it how do I
get the actual graph out here I I don't
think there is a way at the moment um
okay but so um give me an example so
let's say i do a carry tree 3/2 or
something that's a boring one how do i
do an interesting carry tree 5 um how do
i get something which is a where i can
actually see that it's layering the
graph plots um I'd say 4 - oh I don't
know what am I doing here what do I need
here 8 - no Charles what what should I
do here where I can tell the difference
well the thing is that I mean
for small-size about a million sold
90,000 fantasies we kind of detect that
and pick the right layout so that's why
that's how that's happening especially
for Carrie tree we kind of know that
okay fine fine fine fine okay so look
the issue we have is this thing here
which has been done with a layered graph
plot yes but we want this to be an
actual graph Jonathan can you just
extract from your code right now the
graph that turns into this
did we lose Jonathan hello if we lost
Jonathan could we ask him to try mr.
well they did if if if the zoom thing
isn't working I suggest you call on our
phone to the zoom in action was just
muted okay can you give us a graph here
rather than the the plot the actual
graph so we can try what Charles just
said about using graph layout sure do
you want me to send that to someone or
yeah you can just send it to me
yep I'll see if I can do that okay so
Charles's claim is that if I just take
this if I well let's just take a Charles
how do I actually see this in some
reasonable way let's take a random graph
let's say 20 nodes this that's really
boring okay how do I do this as a
layered graph plot so I would say so you
see comic roughly out goes to layered
crap embedding layer
often bedding by the way why isn't that
in the autocomplete that seems to be a
bug
Sushma can use um layered graph
embedding yes
is that new oh right so we detect that
is not actually a layered curve so we
don't do that shouldn't I give a message
in that case Charles yes but this is
more Auto visualization we kind of
reduce amount of message okay okay how
do I get a layered graph click on so if
you just go to graph layout
documentation we have example inside on
and on so if you go to scope and a
vertex layout section there is on
example a bottom why is everything open
here that's a bug in three okay where do
I want to go layered embedding yes
so these layered embedding and layered
d-caf embedding when is it directed
cough well this is a directed graph
right Jonathan
yep it's 30s directed right
okay did you did you manage to extract a
graph for us to try yeah well I mean how
would I go about sending it over just
send email just what do you mean take
the graph shown copy it and send email
or alternatively we can look at your
screen but I think it's easier if you
just send it by email um we could be
very high-tech and we could use the chat
system but it probably won't work for
right now okay so again can you make
sure by the way also Charles with these
autocompletes for the thing you just
said also the layered whatever it was
the the directed graph thing that that
also gets correctly and inserted into
the autocomplete yes we've talked
oh yeah we just goes that to the okay um
okay so while we're waiting Jonathan oh
oh did you get this email sent okay we
also need to look at that other
representation of the proof that was
what is this this is what is this thing
here this this mock-up that was sent
what is that yes so this morning we were
discussing natural deduction diagrams
with Jamie and rather than having a line
separating the premises from the
completion we thought that these two
colors what is natural deduction I'm
sorry is that is that like old-fashioned
Frager stuff
it's called Jensen's style and it's this
idea of having lines separating the I
think that came from the paragraph 50
thing of frege's modified by Jensen I
would suspect of it I see um okay we
also have support for a Hilbert style
things as well but yes that's that's a
piano star proof explain because I don't
know and then what does the Hilbert
style proof look like that so well I
mean this is this is the new design for
Jonathan your email was empty just just
take the notebook take a thing in a
notebook and attach it oh maybe this one
isn't empty now we have lemon tea that
has the input form yes okay fine okay so
here we go so this is what is all this
junk so this is so actually this is
relevant for Charles to see this is the
thing okay so that's that graph right
with a bunch of directed edges yes okay
so now Charles is claim is so let's just
see what this looks like
did we or did it to automatically detect
that it was loud yes well so what's the
problem
Jonathan
the problem is solved yes I mean when I
was developing the layer grafting I was
using an older external build and the
graph laid out very differently to that
so this may just be the only issue you
may have is the detection of the wood
vertex right in some case you know we I
mean we don't understand with coffee
just torch I look at the coffin in can
you can you hint it with the root vertex
yes there is an option where you can see
what that takes and then you specify the
actual hoots okay so Jonathan that's
what you need to do mm-hmm
yeah let me just take the I guess the
most densely connected axiom or
something and specify that's the root is
that what you want to do as opposed to
take all the accidents and specify them
as the root can we do that Charles no
the thing essentially is that we are
allies the graph and try to find out who
they may be you know we may find out it
is two hoots so we pick one by default
so the point is is you know do you know
if your cough harvest you know in
manhood or save all of them that's kind
of the issue if your cough like in this
case what you have actually two on the
top there yes it's the problem could be
that the root is actually the end node
which is that the graph is kind of
reversed right then you see do you know
the arrow goes up white instead of you
wait a second okay but but but okay just
to get this picture what you're saying
is that that Jonathan should put in here
graph layout goes to something or other
um how about Sushma sends mail to
Charles and Jonathan to connect them and
how about Charles tells Jonathan what
option to put in here but otherwise this
looks like it's working beautifully
great um does does this automatically
lose labels or does this or did you tell
it to lose labels Jonathan I told her to
lose labels would it automatically lose
them Charles no but it will do
which changed automatic so if there are
labels we always display labels so and
are we do we think this is so vertex
style so these are the names of the
vertices like substitution lemma 3 right
and these are the color palette which
Jeremy is specifying a better one off or
something yep and
dashing small small um I mean I I would
like to suggest that we try um
instead of -
more small why not we tried dotted and
there a thing called dotted I haven't
used this in forever
try it
come on
that's really weird
oh right because some coffees are object
so we replace doesn't go inside after
you build it
growl growl now there is another
solution here which is really grotesque
I don't even do this in in it and copy
dashing small small how do I get the
innards of the thing without um how
would I get the innards of that graph
object there we go doesn't that look
matter if I might don't you think that
looks better
what's goodly it looks pretty light at
least through my session like they could
be tighter the dots are good I just feel
like they're they're loose
you mean the dots could be closer
together yeah well that may be a new
with how dotted works in general which
is a question for Bret
we could also okay
I think it looks better to have
something less coarse so that should
respect somehow I agree that it looks
they look kind of silly relative to the
arrows at the end again explain Jonathan
one more time these are things where why
isn't there a sequence where the
substitutions are just being followed
down in solid lines why that why are
there bunch of things were there only
dotted lines well says so for the
critical pair lemmers there are only
dotted lines because so if you have some
equation like a equals B you can that
you could that equation can be used in
two two ways you can either take that
equation and apply some rule to it or
you can take the equation and convert it
into a rule so that a goes to B or B
goes to a and so the dotted lines are
showing where you're converting an
equation to a rule and the solid lines
are where you're taking an equation and
applying a rule to it and deducing some
other equation so with the critical
parameters which are the orange ones
you only have rule because a critical
pear lemma is is is there's no
substitution it's a it's an entirely
rule based thing and then with the
substitution lemmas which are the yellow
ones there you have an input and the
rule what is Green Green is the
hypothesis what are taking out red is
the next okay so listen guys come on
these have got a is there any chance of
us okay so the point is these things
here go with the dotted lines basically
right so what would make more sense it
seems to me would be to color those
dotted lines something which which sort
of resonates with the color used for the
critical pears sure why yellow is the
color associated I mean why isn't that a
bluish color that goes with or whatever
color goes with the color of the things
that actually represent those
substitutions what I'm saying yep and
then in terms of the I mean it's kind of
weird that the axiom is red stop and the
hypothesis is green go that seems just
weird to me now is there any possibility
this is I guess a question for Charles
is there any possibility of an IKE of
any iconography other than a circle here
that won't mess up um yes we can put in
it in there as long as we adjust it
correct
yes well what would you suggest I mean
like do we have standard symbols for
graph elements no except this circle is
there anything other than a circle
that's standard Esquire but beside that
I usually circle or square but I mean
you're just stating but do the arrows
correctly hit a shape of a different
shape so to speak yes so long as it's
approximated my polynomial um what so
what I mean is that the you know here is
a circle so we can actually compute the
distance if you put an image we may make
a mistake okay so what for what would we
not make a mistake anything which is a
classic you'll see that so classic build
from spline b-spline or a coffee
committee interesting okay so do we have
a thought therefore what these should be
then if so what would naturally I mean
to me these things would be naturally
some kind of arrow down like they're
being introduced I don't know or some
some some start is that some symbol in I
mean look for example this is almost
like it's the it's the square for the
QED at the end yeah I I think the
standard would be to use a kind of
tombstones square for the conclusion and
a I I may be wrong but I think the
standard is a sort of diamond for axioms
but I can check that they're definitely
asked of conventions on proof networks
but in terms of the shapes of the nodes
really okay well then what's the shape
of the node for a critical pair that
probably doesn't think that mean because
critical players tend not to be a part
of a feature of human proofs there there
really is only a kind of thing that
you're saying if we look at if we look
for a proof a typeset proof you think
that there will be decoration
the you think that the I mean certainly
the QED is decorated with a with a quad
or something
printers quad thingy and you're saying I
don't think I have a proof readily at
hand here let me see um you're saying
that there's some decoration that will
be a um
see if I say proof and I go to images oh
my gosh you do not get the kite type of
proof that we think
you
here we go here are some images it's
kind of amusing okay so here that is
like Russell and Whitehead isn't it
something yep um that weird thing there
what is that weird thing there that
weird thing there is a that's a semantic
implication I think okay
see
that's not really proof writing okay oh
that's one of those some
50 thingies isn't it I mean that's one
of those yep thing you're calling a
natural deduction proof right
okay that's not really the same thing
oh I noticed that they're using proof
with them that is a pretty common thing
to use proof with small caps like that I
wonder if we should do that too
and in the printout type thing
full oh that's fun okay
huh
my god that's another thing of mine okay
that's a bad sign when you look up
something thinking you're gonna find all
kinds of stuff in the outside world and
you find stuff that you wrote yourself
that is a bad sign for the for the
general interest of them and that has to
be one of ours too you know who knows
okay
um
that's different all right um okay so
look it sounds like a little bit of work
should be done trying to figure out what
these icons should be let's talk about
okay so is that everything we needed
from Charles anything else from Charles
about graphs so so the end result of
this is that proof network should we
call it proof network uh proof graph
if it's returning a graph object and
proof graph seems like the natural
choice fine why are we calling a proof
graph rather than just graph
I'm given that it is in a proof object
let's take a look at what we've got here
we could just call it
well they're bad Babar look you can't
call some of them proof and some of them
walk right you can't call it
human-readable I would call that
notebook why don't we call it Graf okay
so here's a possibility we could call it
we could call this one validation
function
well the we initially called it
verification but there were there were
various reasons for referred for
renaming at proof function namely the
fact that it's only actually verifying
the the substitution lemmers and the
rule applications there are aspects of
the proofs of that that function will
not verify particularly all right fine
so look maybe what we should call it as
proof steps proof Network proof notebook
um
proof written out in a notebook that
makes sense yep um now you said you've
got some other things which of these
natural production things right yes
they're not documented because the that
they will be broken in the version that
you are currently using because we
restructured the proof objects okay what
is proof steps it's proof steps really a
list of proof steps or is it something
different
it's a data set was like I should
rewrite that well then why don't we say
you know there is a certain argument
that we should just name this this one
graph what do you think guys if we
called that graph data set
my okay so this may not be a good
argument but my justification for using
the proof prefix was that we have these
accesses like theorem and axioms and we
also have a we have said logic and
things they're not features of the proof
itself you know you're like and metadata
features of them all right fine I'm sold
so let's say are we gonna call it proof
graph for proof Network roof graph is
probably fine yeah okay so proof dataset
proof steps as a data set is there any
other form that we want not as a data
set like as an actual list
it's pretty much unreadable as a list I
mean we can we originally did format it
that way but I think I think the feeling
in the ILD meeting is the data set was
more natural we could offer both if you
think that well I don't know it's that
if there's some programmatic reason why
the list is more useful that might be
worth having sure but I mean I think
your justification was that the list is
sort of trivially extractable from the
data set anyway okay
um okay what would happen if you took a
proof object you just said graph of this
proof object is that can we make that
work or data set of that proof object
that would be nice if it worked I think
you can be working through up values if
you know how to set those up yeah we're
going to get okay
so then we need to make sure that we
document that um
you
etc okay okay all right
can we loop back um do you want to show
it okay was there anything else for I'm
sorry was there anything else for
Charles here about this graph
nope okay unless wait a minute the
collision of these labels is there
anything Charles do you have any
thoughts about that is there anything we
can do there is that just hopeless well
we're actually working on the general a
building I'll go in for to avoid a
collision so unless you actually know
yourself you know the length then you
can specified it so what we do know the
length I mean we don't know the font
rendering right like yes okay
well I think you're in the trees meeting
on tree Charles which is gonna be a few
minutes late so okay see you there um
okay so can we can we look at this
natural deduction thing for a minute and
then I want to talk about this resource
object thing um sure I mean should we
look at your screen for the natural
deduction thing yep I can show that
hang-up okay meanwhile let's talk for a
second about the okay that's good okay
you managed to make that work wait a
minute that was that that was the redone
I I was halfway through it it's not it's
not complete but yeah I was okay good
yeah okay let's take this and I should
know let me start with a simple example
so what are we doing so that I think
that we experimented with a few
different formats like that like the
original one I think we did was this and
then there's a there's a more verbose
version that's in my view not not as
nice but I think I think the well
whatever is true it shouldn't be textual
we might as well use graphical elements
and these things yes yes I agree and so
I think the one that we decided on was
the natural deduction concise and that
this is the this is the objects that
corresponds to the mock-up that I think
Jeremy sent you
so the idea is that so so for each
intermediate proof step what we have is
sort of we have two or three boxes
saying what's going into this proof step
and then we have a we have a line and
then a box saying what's coming out of
proof step okay okay
what seems reasonable and does that work
when things get long does it go crazy or
not I mean everything goes a little bit
crazy but I let me take a slightly
longer one of the various formats we
experimented with we thought this was
the most read this is hard to read
because we don't have very good spacing
between these but if if we use the if we
use the format that Jeremy sent over and
we space these out a bit more I think
this is probably the most readable we
can make it so Jeremy's mock-up has
boxes so it has three things on the top
floor of each one of these yes so so
there it has three things because in
that particular case there was a that
was the proof of a critical Palermo
which always takes which has a happens
to take three inputs and evaluate to one
thing for a substitution on it only
takes two inputs okay so what does it
look like in that case then it just has
two separators I mean it has just one
separator in that case yeah I guess so
why is that thing with a colon
I mean why have the thing see the thing
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
the output you're having a colon in the
output which is just why not make it
graphical the fact that there's a colon
there make that more graphical I agree
so I mean I was wondering if it might
even make sense given them
so we're saying take axiom two axiom one
and it evaluates to a equals C but then
maybe we just title this thing a
substitution number one does that make
any I don't make sense to me I just
don't know how bizarre that will be to
people who are into these kinds of
natural deduction proof things no I mean
as a natural deduction format I think
that's perfectly fine it okay so Jeremy
Jeremy still with us yeah I am yeah um
but you want to bring up Jeremy's email
on-screen no I can go to it other okay
so here
so the issue is we don't really need
okay the main event is we are producing
that critical pear lemma - we are doing
that by feeding in this this in this
right charlie yeah
so
anything is if we can label the thing if
maybe this is just simply a colored
background down here although I don't
know how that's going to work because
this is it's like this and this and this
goes to this which is this
well yeah but labeled as critical there
is the whole thing they know the output
is labeled isn't that correct the output
this is the proof of critical pair lemma
two Krista here is the proof of critical
pair lemma two which means this that
this output is critical pair lemma two
and what goes into that is axiom - axiom
one on this yeah still feels like it
could go above then in that case none
yes it can go above okay
I like the idea of it do you think you
can come up with a format Jeremy for it
to go above them yeah I think so I don't
even think it needs to be in the box
long as it's above and typeset right I
think we can keep what we have fine
there's not something really quicker and
do we actually think that it's better to
have the conclusion be gray B are gray
background rather than the things going
into the conclusion beyond a gray
background other words what's the most
emphasized thing here
dick Aleutian I would see yeah I see it
right but that should be the most
emphasized but the fact that's on a gray
background might make it seem less
emphasized I heared more that's why I
did that it just popped a little more
when you read yeah yeah because the
burger ons wait fine okay
okay did you say you had some Hilbert
based proof thingy well I mean sorry
so by the way this is so
this would just be a proof object this
will be natural deduction quotes natural
deduction form is that right yeah I
think so okay and then you said there
was some other form the hilbert form
also well that yeah the these more
verbose forms that I was showing you
earlier these are closer to what I think
is known as being like a Hilbert style
natural deduction
what more verbose forms you mean the
ones in the notebook yes okay
but I feel like even with the
appropriate typesetting I don't think
those are going to be particularly
informative right okay let's talk about
your collection of axiom systems and so
on okay so your point is that each axiom
system comes with certain operators and
so on right yep and so the question is
what you would really like to be able to
do
is to have something where for a given
axiom system you feed it some
association that tells it you know it
gives you an association that has the
[Music]
tells you what the parameters like the
names of the operators are and so on and
then you give it some other names of
operators or something right yeah I mean
ideally you'd have some we'd have some
kind of default list of operators but
the user could override them if
necessary right I mean the yucky thing
of course about these operators is that
they wind up in the in the
context by the way this is some
can we have the money formal symbols or
we could accept formal symbols right now
are incredibly ugly although we would
like to change that I mean they'll be
dotted all over the place with formal
symbols yes I think we're gonna have to
use formal symbols any not for the
operators but for the quantified
variables because otherwise we're gonna
end up with loads of symbols just
produced in global context fair enough
ok but but then ok so now the question
is in what form I mean so my proposal
was that that basically we just have a
single resource and we just say resource
data collection of axiom systems or
whatever it's called
and then it just says then there you
know Robinson arithmetic or something
right
so the resource object itself would be
an association that's the idea there I
mean the the content of the resource
object will be an association that just
says Robinson arithmetic arrow that
right yeah
now is it the case um I mean each one is
just an axiom system right all type
axiom system
yeah it'll allow you to be a single
quantified axiom or it'll be a list of
axioms
right I mean in each one we are also
going to want a collection of notable
theorems for each axiom system so
ultimately
I mean arguably maybe this should be an
association which contains the axiom
system it's going to be axioms which are
going to be a list of axioms right right
and then
I mean we're gonna want other things
like notable theorems probably sure I
like the idea of having axiom system
metadata my only concern is that I
thought it week it's nice if we could
just say sort of find equational proof
and then have just put in resource data
collection oxygen systems robertson
arithmetic as our axiom system yes oh
let's look at Jeremy's markup here
that looks just fine to me I like the
way that worked out
with that anybody okay can you is that
is that was that just Photoshop or is
this code that Photoshop I was gonna get
some a list object and try to type
thethis though so I think that's coming
to me okay well I bet Jonathan could do
it too um okay
okay so look the alternative would be
how many axiom systems do we have right
now I think the idea is to have all of
the all of the equational axiom systems
that are on the two axiom pages of nks
which I think comes about 15 maybe 19
okay so I think there are a few others I
mean you know do we think they're like
another 10 or something out in the world
yeah I've seen a few for sort of various
areas of universal algebra that we might
want to introduce so yeah but what about
what about things that have nothing to
do with stuff like this but of things
like axiom systems representing
protocols representing you know pieces
of Wolfram language like the axiom
system for you know join append prepend
those kinds of things if we can express
them equation lis than they might be
worth including I don't know you know I
mean some of those things I think okay
so let's let's just understand our
choices because I agree with you that
just being able to feed something into
um ah well if all we have initially
I mean ultimately we're going to want a
thing that is called something like
what will be the I mean what we have you
know we have this thing called net model
which is furn you're nuts okay I mean I
wonder whether we could just have a
thing called axiom system and then a
name yeah I mean we prototype that with
the original theory and it worked quite
well
really okay well where where is that
that's not in the current builds because
we it was decided in the ILD meeting
rather than having an equation theory we
should just have a single resource
Association but I still have that code
somewhere why don't you why don't we why
don't you get that code back out and
let's look at it again okay let's see
whether
um is this the right way to call it
axiom system data or something
Aksum system data of robinson arithmetic
is there any reason for the data being
there if we if we only wanted to return
a list of axioms shouldn't it just be
axiom system and there maybe there's
axiom system data which has some
metadata in it about notable theorems
whatever but Steven are we going in the
direction of converting this into
entities
oh yes that is the direction we're going
in yes because then this could link to
Michael's project of theorems in general
axes other example you know where we're
storing the stuff proofs thanks
um that that's right that's a good idea
so so we could have an entity store
a different idea which is a built-in
entity store of these things
well I see or the other possibility is a
resource object that is an entity store
is that what you're effectively
suggesting Jose I'm not sure but having
entities behind these could be very
flexible yeah I agree
all right we need to go to a different
meeting um let's see if if Jonathan if
you can just I mean well it wherever
your raw data is just put it in a
notebook and send it out to us
okay the raw data on these Isum systems
so they can see what exists and then I
think you know putting that data into an
entity store whether it is whatever is
happening to it that will be a good
thing to do to it okay and then then
what will happen is that the entity
Robinson arithmetic or something if you
feed that to find equational proof see
that the trouble is you need the
operators right you need to know what
the operators are to write down theorems
you can't write the terms without
knowing the operators um but the work I
have defaults yeah and if the whole
entity is parametrized by the by the set
of operators then in addition to the
axioms having the operators and the
things like the notable theorems we'll
also have the user-defined operators in
the stuff like that I just think it's
it's its nicest if we if we allowed the
if we allow the whole axiom system
entity to be parametrized by the
operators yeah but then then it can't be
a single entity because it's got to be a
parameterised it's got to be a function
right
I see so what
you're saying is so it would be axiom
system and then then effectively I mean
so one other model would be axiom system
here um of Robinson arithmetic oops
Robinson arithmetic and then we would
have to say Association you know plus
goes to
F or something x goes to G right what
you have in mind
yep
with a default
that doesn't look very entity like does
it I think we should talk to Michael
about this yeah there might be an entity
instance or some variant that Phelps
left a good idea
you
an interesting idea all right
okay can you can you ask Michael about
that Jose yes I can sure okay all right
I think it's some time to go to the next
meeting um all right so thanks Jonathan
talk to you soon go say bye